- Hey, can I steal you for a moment?
Is that okay?
I just really need to tell you something.
(jazzy music)
(text alerts)
- Kelly, what do you wanna do today?
- That's not my name.
- Kasey?
- No.
- Kristina.
- Candice?
- No.
- Kelsey A.
- No!
- Sarah?
- This place is amazing.
- Anything for you.
- Who are you?
- Oh, this is a group date.
- Hi, I'm mentally unstable,
but I'll find a way to manipulate Chad
into thinking I'm totally normal.
- And I've already been
on two dates with him, so,
he'll probably break up with me tonight.
- I haven't seen my kids in eight weeks!
- I just feel like he doesn't
even listen to me anymore.
- Yeah, I'm gonna need all of that again,
but, like, a little more concise,
and if we can get some hysterical crying,
that'd be fantastic.
Did you get your drink before this scene?
Andrew, Andrew, did she get the champagne?
- Do you want to go back to
the Fantasy Suite with me?
- "Fantasy Suite?"
- Sex.
I'm talking about sex.
- Danni, I know we
haven't known each other
for very long, but,
will you marry me?
(record player needle scratches)
- No!
I've known you for eight weeks.
You always are bringing
around other women.
And you're always trying to get me drunk!
Eh!
(jazzy music)